liebe frau von der leyen herzlich
willkommen
es freut mich sehr dass ich ab sofort
nicht mehr der seriöseste vertreter der
europäischen demokratie bin
das personaltableau dass der rat
vorgelegt hat hat es in sich
josef oehrlein spanische typ der als
präsident des europäischen
hochschulinstituts zurücktreten musste
weil er vergessen hatte eine jährliche
gratifikation von 300.000 euro zu
erwähnen soll als außenbeauftragte die
europäischen werte in der welt vertreten
christine lagarde eine juristin die
wegen veruntreuung von 400 millionen
euro öffentlicher gelder schuldig
gesprochen wurde und noch nie eine
nationale notenbank geführt hat soll die
ezb leiten schauen wie schnell ein
belgier der nicht einmal in belgien eine
funktionierende regierung bilden konnte
soll ratspräsident werden und für den
ausgleich der in einem immer komplexeren
geflecht nationaler interessen sorgen
und dazu sie frau von der leyen ein
europa politisch völlig kenntnis freie
deutsche ministerin die lediglich durch
einen irren hang zu überteuerten
beratern missmanagement und euphemismen
aufgefallen ist
trendwende finanzen für die größte
deutsche auf rüstungs kampagne seit
kriegsende
um diese parade von inkompetenz und
moralischer wurstigkeit abzusichern
taktieren sie mit der liberalen partei
dem möchtegern faschisten orban und
benito salvini wir sollten europa nicht
den laien überlassen
zwinker smiley vielen dank
[Applaus]